I've heard you say you're like
introverted yeah and yet you're able to
put yourself out on social media how
because something I'm struggling with is
overcoming the friction of like hitting
post for some reason like I've edited a
lot of standup Clips I shot sketches
this weekend and I was like oh I'm gonna
post all of them one a day and then I
posted one and then I re-edited it and
then posted it again today like like I I
don't um for some reason there's like a
a disconnect between like me creating
something and then actually hitting
publish is yeah why help me it's hard
it's well it's a it's a it is it's a
muscle you know it really is like I I
struggle with that too uh it's um and I
think that for me what made
it what made me do it is that I was
doing it on Tik Tok which felt very um
anonymous because I didn't have F like I
it took me a long time to be able to
transition the the stuff I was doing on
Tik Tok onto Instagram because I was
like Instagram is where the people I
know exist and I am
afraid to be embarrassed and to you know
to to feel like they're
seeing to be vulnerable so I just I just
put stuff on Tik Tok because I was like
ah I don't know anyone on Tik Tok um and
like little by little because there's
something about just like it kind of
felt like I was just like throwing it
into the abyss and it was like it'll
either hit or it won't and if it doesn't
it doesn't matter No One's Gonna See It
um that's a that's a that's such a
different thought process than most
comedians have which is nah I don't want
everything out right like it's feels
like you were just like you just let the
wind fly you're like all right it
doesn't matter uh yeah yeah I didn't
yeah I didn't feel precious about it at
all I was just like I'll just try this
uh because I'm not doing anything else
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
fantastic um and now so you said you you
shouted in April and uh when was it
released uh uh Tuesday last Tuesday so
what was the process between the shoot
and last Tuesday in terms of like I
guess maybe something I don't know if
anyone knows or not but in my mind you
shoot a special and then you kind of
release it because we've talked to a lot
of comics as well it's like oh they just
put it out as soon as they kind of
release it and the time when it was shot
versus the time that it was released
sort of what was the process between
that and to sell it instead of putting
it just on YouTube as well seems like
going another path here well it was it
was a lot of it was not in my um control
because it was produced by comedy
Dynamics um and so that all happened
like in like comedy Dynamics just kind
of like handled it all like they did all
of the pitching I was it was Hands-On in
terms of like editing they we went back
and forth for several edits um like
several rounds of notes they did an
amazing job um and they were very like
they took all of the notes they wanted
me to feel really happy about it um but
in terms of the of the back end like
selling and getting it out there that
was um that was just their their
production company um yeah yeah so um
you know I know a lot of comics will
will shoot it on their own and and try
to sell it pitch it around and then if
it doesn't land they'll just put it out
on YouTube which is a very great option
nowadays um I think but in this case it
was like they just comedy Dynamics just
handled all of that which made it uh
easy for
me yeah and Jerry asked how the comedy
Dynamics get
involved how' you work comedy Dynamics
um contracted me to do it so essentially
like they they um so fancy I know I was
it was really exciting it was really
exciting back in um I mean they hired me
they so back in um last December maybe
um my manager called me in and he was
like Hey comedy Dynamics is doing this
Festival where they're going to be
shooting like a handful of our specials
they're looking specifically for people
who have like bigger social media
platforms do you want to shoot an hour
in April and I was like sure even though
at that time
I didn't have an hour I had 40 minutes
um because I had just started headlining
um you know as a result of this like
social media growth I had just like it
was just the beginning of that so it was
basically just like a fast track of like
from January to April I just like I just
hit the road so hard and there's
something really useful to having a
deadline
because like if you had told me that I
would write like an extra an additional
20 minutes in like four months I would
have been like no that's not possible
but it's like if you have a deadline you
you force yourself to do it you
know yeah so I just I just I just
traveled really hard for four months and
um got up I was just on the road
Non-Stop and uh got the hour in shape to
a place that I wanted it and yeah
and uh Michelle asked have you already
started writing your next
special I have I I it's been an
interesting process of sort of like
figuring out how
to you know sort of like release and an
ad and and
um
like I at this point
I because because it's this it's this
tricky thing where like I don't have a
full new hour yet um
but I also don't want to be going back
to the same cities and going to cities
where people have seen the special and
doing what they've already seen so it's
been it's been a fast sort of I'm
turning over as fast as I can uh so
right now it's my my hour is sort of
like half of what is in the hour that's
out now and half new stuff and my goal
is to have a full new hour by um I guess
by by April of
2024 very cool well let's
um let's let's get in let's get into
social media let let's get into the
Weeds on social media um and I do see
Ben asked really quick he he started in
Chicago and
um he works in smaller markets gets
booked in smaller markets should he move
somewhere more Central
than Chicago or um stay and grind in
Chicago I think Chicago is an amazing
City to uh to be in yeah um I mean you
have Chicago is an incredible comedy
scene they have so many great rooms
there and you have access to so many
like Midwestern markets I I uh and at
this point you can
do you could do what you're doing
anywhere like it you know I think that
Chicago is a really good place to be
unless you feel a driving force to I
mean the I think the only the only other
options would be New York or LA but I I
think in terms of you know if you want
to get the most stage time possible New
York is the place to go but
um I think Chicago is probably right
after
that for
sure yeah good uh good question though
yeah you can really do it from anywhere
and you're you're an example of that in
terms of just like seeing it work I
guess we're all trying to figure out
social media I mean I've interviewed I
just interviewed like Joey Avery who
recently like blew up doing crowd work
stuff and uh Jean Marco Seri who also
blew up doing crowd work stuff but
you're doing you found it from just like
oh instead of me having to like go to a
show which you still post some stand up
but like the lift of going to a show
setting up a camera having audio post
editing and all of that instead of just
setting up a camera with a light and
just being like here's something funny
like that sounds way more sustainable so
like what is what is kind of your
production process it sound like you had
a writing partner like let's get into
the Weeds on kind of like your creation
around like consistent social media
content yeah I mean I I do everything um
everything I do on my own it's all it's
all just me um I I just have a I have a
a Google doc that is just at this point
I don't know 150 pages
of literally yeah like it's just called
Tik Tok brainstorms and I just uh I
don't know that's just how I that's just
kind of How It's unfolded and I just
I get in there and I just write I just I
just brainstorm um and it's gotten a
little bit harder with being on the road
to keep up the consistency uh but I try
and also it just is like it's fun for me
so it doesn't feel like a chore like my
favorite thing to do is is make is make
these these videos like it it really
like it does fill my soul so
um yeah I I mean I I just will sit down
and I'll be like okay I want to write
you know a like a wealthy woman today
and let me just try to think of let me
just pick a place and um and then it
often starts with just like a phrase
that I that is funny to me and I'll just
kind of build on that um and then I just
I shoot it I usually shoot it the same
day um I shoot everything in my house I
mean this is like the backdrop that I
use
for all of my wealthy woman videos um
and it's just it's just my phone and a
and a ring light um it's pretty it's
pretty straightforward um with standup
shows I bought like a nice camera and um
I think that was like a really good
investment and I still I film all of my
shows and if you know if there's a piece
of crowdwork that I really love I will
clip that up I I taught myself how to
use premere Pro um like super basic the
super basic concepts um and I really
like editing too so for me it's all um I
really like love the I love every like
aspect of of
producing short short comedy
videos that's
fantastic this um AB he had asked and he
actually asked um he posted this
question before we went live um on
YouTube and then um then all that
happened but um he said if skits or
sketches are not something you're
comfortable
with um what content would you recommend
posting other than standup and crowdwork
to help grow your
audience um I mean I think that that's
super specific to each person you know I
don't make I don't
make character videos because I I think
that that's what I'm supposed to do I do
it
because that's what I love to do so I
think it's
finding finding what is fun for you to
do what feels fun and funny and you know
it doesn't have to be a sketch it can be
it can be like you taking your camera
and and you know a joke that you're
working on for standup trying to do that
like straight to camera like trying to
adjust it so that it's like you're just
like yourself like walking down on the
street saying this thing I mean there's
there's a million different ways and I
think it's just an issue of a
qu like speaks to you as a as a Creator
as a as an artist as a comic what what
makes you laugh you
know yeah that's interesting yeah the
the fun thing is really resonating with
me as most of what I've tried to create
so far has like felt like something
either I needed to create or I'm
supposed to be creating but it's not
necessarily something I'm maybe like as
excited about yeah I think that that I
think that that's something that that we
forget a lot because it's like oh in
like this idea that oh in order to get
ahead we're supposed to be doing these
things we're supposed to be posting
we're supposed to be clipping up
stuff
and it like it doesn't I think it
there's s sort of like an energetic
thing it doesn't work like that like it
it's like you have to I think that it's
so important to come from a place of
like an organic desire to um to say
something to make something like it not
for the purpose of I should be doing
this you know I think it's easier said
than done because obviously like there
is like an element of business which is
like okay you have to there has to be
some consistency and there has to be
some you know output but um I think it's
really important to like take a step
back and be like what like is feeding my
soul what is what is like making me
giggle you know and not what I think the
world wants to see yeah not what I think
I'm supposed to be putting out there
what I want to put out there because it
it Delights
me yeah I think I heard you say that
before in an interview was like anytime
you tried to post something for the
algorithm or that saw other people doing
it would tank yeah yeah anytime I've
done something where I've been like oh
this
is uh this is going to be like a winner
you know because I've yeah exactly
because I've seen it work for other
people yeah the stuff that like does
really well is stuff that is stuff that
I'm like I really don't I can't imagine
anyone else would but I'll just put it
out and see you know and like stuff that
I think is is not going to work in all
is often what like goes viral because I
think people respond to like truth you
know they respond to like
organic
[__] the the most profound that is the
title of the
episode organic [__] yeah that's gonna
be the title of the podcast compost
comedy
yeah that should be your next uh special
I think it will be I think it will be
yeah does um dri asked um how often you
need to post Clips like do we need a
weekly
schedule they say you do I don't know I
like I try to but sometimes I don't I
can't keep up with it you know like I
think on average I post like a few times
a week uh probably on average like three
times a week um sometimes I'll get in if
I'm if it's like a time where like I'm
not touring and I'm like home then I try
to post every day but um I think you
just have to figure out what works for
you and be consistent with that you know
what I mean I mean that's what I've
heard so like if you can post every day
and keep that up that's
awesome twice a week do that
consistently um that's what that's what
that's what they say the powers that be
but I don't know it's all been for me
it's all been trial and error um and I
feel like it still is trial and error I
still don't I don't know how to game the
algorithm any better than anybody else
does it sounds like you know something I
mean well I know something in that I you
know in that I've been sort of obsessed
with it for the past two years um but I
still don't know like I don't know if if
hashtags were like sometimes hasht
ultimately I think none of that stuff
matters as much as we think it does what
matters is
sharing organic [__] yeah like
like what what actually takes off is
stuff that is actually like funny and
good you know and sharable like you said
like something and terrible how how
people almost like like interact now is
they'll just DM reals to each other
that's like part of my feed now almost
is like like my DM getting like reals
from people like oh this reminds me of
so and so or such and such like that
connectivity is like a new layer to
content I I think I think I
lost are you there did you lose I lost
yeah I lost I lost a part of your
question oh yeah I was just saying like
you reference like being able to share
it but the sharability seems to be a big
part of like people wanting to send it
to a friend and they can kind of like
connect over this piece of content yeah
totally you see something that resonates
and you're like oh this is like what
this person does this this yeah I think
that is a big part but I I don't it's um
I don't know for me it's hard to
manufacture that right like I can't I
can't reverse engineer it I can't be
like well what is going to what is going
to be a thing that someone else wants to
send to their friend like
it it doesn't for me it it doesn't work
like that every time I've tried to like
reverse engineer something it's like
crashed and
burned so is it an instinct like what
yeah what what's going on over there
what is what you what do you know over
there Leah what do you know that us
Comics can learn from I I mean I'm just
a weirdo I don't know like I
I'm just like I mean first of all like I
I have been I have been doing comedy for
17 years and so I just know what I like
I know what makes me
laugh um I know how to like write jokes
in a succinct
way and that is something that to a
certain extent can be learned
and you know and and then it's just like
it just is like what it's what I think
is funny I just sit down and I just I
just like write what I think is funny
and I think that that is something that
anyone can do you know
um and there are I think there are ways
to hone that skill uh which is just um
writing consistently and taking in as
much comedy as you can and
um just really doing all the things to
get in touch with uh your your sense of
humor and your voice so what is your
writing process like what's the thing
that you do from a writing perspective
like how do you write do you write daily
do you schedule it out is it spur the
moment sort of what and has that evolved
and then also with your writing process
what do you sort of decide to then put
out to the world like what do you then
decide oh okay I'mma make something on
Tik Tok talk about
this um yeah it's it's kind of an Ever
evolving process and I think I I sort of
delineate it so I'm like okay right now
I'm going to sit down and I'm going to
write stand up or right now I know that
I need to I know that I need and I want
to put out a video today so I'm going to
sit down and do this um and then it's
like just starting with uh I think for
all of it it's like starting with a
subject or a topic so if I sit down and
write standup it's like okay I'm going
to write about you know my marriage
today and and and then it's kind of
just just freew writing I mean I I will
often just set a timer like for 30
minutes and just freewrite um and it's
the same with like Tik Tok and Instagram
videos I'm like okay I want to I want to
write a video today let's pick a
character right so it's like I'll do AAL
woman or I'll do like my love coach
character
um and then I just I just kind of sit
and I I wait for something to click in
and it doesn't always happen um and
there's there's a lot of writers block
and a lot of staring at the wall and
being like why can't I think of anything
to write um and then I don't know and
then something comes and I don't know
where it comes from I like you know like
that's that's how that's how works right
you just like you sit with yourself and
and try to get out of your own way and
um and sometimes you can and sometimes
you can't and sometimes I sit and I
write stuff and I'm like this is trash
and um and then I just have to put it
away for the day I mean it's it's hard
it's not like it's fun when it clicks in
and like there's a flow because then
it's like then it's easy right you're
like oh I'm like this I'm just like
sitting here with my like like thoughts
and it's I'm making myself giggle but
but but 75% of the time it's like this
is horrible why like what is wrong like
why can't I do
this does that answer your question I I
mean it's it does because that sounds
about normal that's about yeah that's so
important to hear that we're like oh my
gosh she has millions of followers
everything must just be magic and every
day she wakes up and is like oh how
should I go viral
today it's like literally you're just
showing up and doing all the grunt work
and then the distillation of all this
hard work and staring at the wall yeah
and
self-denial you just keep sitting
through that and that's when you start
to find like the the things wor keeping
yeah and I think that is just the I I
think you know I think we all know that
that is that is just the process to
making anything that's you know it's
it's a lot of like
it's a lot of of uh of finding tricks to
get out of your own way um and more
often the not it doesn't it doesn't work
I
think do do you have like um a video or
like a script structure at this point of
like okay I know I need a laugh in the
first 7 seconds or 30 seconds works
better than if the video is 40 5 Seconds
do you have like a like a formula like
that like um like uh how do can you how
do you mean so I've heard like in the
YouTube World especially in like shorts
they're like all right you got to have a
hook and then set up the thing you're G
to pay off at the end but for like for
your sketches do you have it broken down
into like okay I have this topic I want
to do about this wealthy woman talking
about this topic and now I know I need a
joke like at five seconds at 15 seconds
like like how many laughs along the way
are more I don't think that I I don't
think that I I uh
I I break it down in a in an exact
timeline like that I I just try to make
as many jokes as I can uh as many jokes
as I can possibly shove in yeah and like
with the wealthy Woman videos there's
kind of a formula there right I it's
like it starts off with like with I
think a like a hook where it's just like
did you know this thing so I think that
that's the hook where it's like people
are responding to to like oh I'm going
to get a piece of information here that
I didn't have before and
um and then I just like I I just try to
I just try to write a a joke every every
sentence you know and it you can't it
doesn't always work but like
that's that's the goal and I'll I'll
like write a rough draft and then I'll
go back and I'll be like how can I punch
this up how can I make this line funnier
how what word can I adjust here that is
like you know like should I use the word
like like I put out one yesterday where
I was like should I use the word Pusser
is that is or is there a funnier word
than Pusser like
right P was that was the right word I I
watched it it was pretty solid it was
cling my pearls over
here is is Tik Tok GNA ban me if I use
the word Pusser you know so it's also
that's also another thing where like I
my mind veers toward dirty like I I like
dirty jokes I like sex jokes I like poop
jokes but um it's been like an
interesting challenge because Tik Tok
and and in less so Instagram but but Tik
Tok is really like uh they'll just take
your video down and so it's been a it's
been like a kind of a good ex experiment
in um or challenge in like writing at
the top of your intelligence where I'm
like I can't I can't just say the word
[__] because I know they're going to
ban me so I'll try the word Pusser
that's not an example of writing at the
top of your intelligence but you know
what I
mean it's
like just ER just we'll just ER it we
and see what happens yeah yeah sometimes
having like a framework like that is
helpful though right because it's like
sometimes being like having boundaries
um I think is
useful
boundaries I guess I yeah like I mean
like um this therapy what is um like
a basically like as like your uh Denny's
and Waffle House I I love those two
clips and like but in your mind I love
how you sort of take people to that
place and then I'm visualizing
everything that I'm seeing at the
Denny's and you describe the people you
describe the stuff that you see so like
is there a framework in your mind or are
you literally just going through that
and are you going to denes and be like
all right what do I see here or you just
like coming up with as many jokes as
possible just trying to like rattle off
from your own experiences I come up with
as many I it's in my it's all in my
brain like or I'll sometimes if I I'll
like Google just to be like what is the
interior of Denny's cuz I haven't been
there in a long time
and I use that as like fod um and then
it's like just just like looking at
something like specifically for the
wealthy Woman character where it's like
what would a person who has no frame of
reference for what this is like no
language for understanding what um you
know what the what what the Cracker
Barrel is yeah what how would she
describe these things with words that
she has yeah so so I guess that's what I
mean by like having a helpful framework
it's just like sometimes being able to
like hone in and
like um it yeah I don't know it
um it just it's I lost my train of
thought all right no no but I get it
though so basically you're you're not
trying to like fill everything you're
just going in from a framework of what
would a wealthy woman that has no
uh frame of reference for what this
restaurant it's almost like if they were
to travel back in time they have no idea
they looked at Denny's what in the world
are they're seeing from their
perspective yeah and it's also for me
just like kind of making lists of what
are the elements to this place like what
are the elements of Denny's like we know
they have the Grand Slam menus we know
they have the the tired waitresses
because it's open all night we know they
have the booth so like so then sort of
projecting on to those things like I so
it is it's a lot of like list making of
like these are the things that this
place has um what would someone who's
never been there who has a very
different reality call them and how can
I make that funny for sure um as you're
doing like a lot of Social Media stuff
have you I guess I don't know if you've
gotten into this world have you thought
about like sponsorships or uh sort of
doing like brand deals or anything like
that as someone who's done social yeah I
mean I would love that uh you know I
would love some more money I uh says the
wealth the wealthy woman talking yeah
I've done I've done a few I did a I did
a few videos for this um company called
Bessa they make like um sex toys which
those were really fun um I did one for
like a like a um alcohol free like a
what are they called um non-alcoholic uh
like liquor thing m MH um but I would
love to do more I I get I get reach out
sometimes and uh you know it has to be
the right it has to be the right fit uh
and I also don't I never want to like
oversaturate with things that feel like
ads because that just doesn't feel good
to
me yeah I just um I just did some shows
did I freeze up again oh your video did
but we heard you okay great oh yeah but
I yeah I just did some shows with a
comedian named Carolyn Xavier who's like
she's been doing a couple years stand up
a couple years but then she blew up
doing this like recovering Californian
character uhuh yeah and U she was
already talking about brain deals she's
done like she got paid a very more than
I got paid for doing the show we were
doing together um for just wearing a hat
in like one of her videos like and I was
just like oh I need to figure this out
and then that's why I ran home and was
like oh I'm gonna she inspired me I'm
shooting sketches and I'm posting them
all week and then I've posted the same
one two days in a row so um why post the
other
ones
yeah why not what's the worst that can
happen your friends will make fun of you
behind your back I don't yeah I don't
know because I've interviewed several
social media people and after the
interview I'm like this is it this is
the time it all changes and then it it
like it's like I I get out of the orbit
of that inspiration and then gravity
just pulls me in the direction of apathy
and complaining so much easier you know
yeah it's true it is it is so much
easier to say you should just do like
like schedule them so that they're just
going out without your without you even
having to like like use that excitement
and just schedule like oh yeah I don't
know just a thought cuz I get it
sometimes I'll be like so excited and
then I'll be like just then your your
head gets in the way and you're like
this is [__] you're
[__] all this organic [__] I don't
organic [__] yeah yeah's what's the
point yeah yeah who cares who cares what
what is my wife gonna say you know those
kind of
[Laughter]
things does your wife does your
wife does she not like your
sketches know she she thinks I'm funny
but like any before I post but just the
way that you said it no no she thinks it
funny she's she she I mean she she likes
the comedy yeah she believes but um yeah
I get nervous of like like if I post
something and she's gonna see it and be
like oh is this what he's doing is is
this like what is happening right now
yeah I yeah I get that I uh just do
it just do it like I like myus that's
what everyone says right everyone
literally says that like everyone we've
interviewed because what else because
what else what's the other option not
doing it and then nothing changes and
then nothing changes yeah I'm posting it
right now yes good but also I I think
like I my husband is like the most
supportive person in the world and I
never show him my stuff before I post it
rarely because you don't like that
anything that is going to even slightly
impede you just putting your stuff out
there you need to get all of the
obstacles out of your way as much as you
can because there's already so many
obstacles in your own brain yeah that's
so good and it literally just reminded
me because you just literally said
earlier finding tricks to get out of
your own way yeah and it's like yeah
like you have to put as many tricks in
your mind like no no no no you're not
going to see it I'm just going to put it
out and we'll figure it out afterwards
yeah like I'm going to sit down and
write I'm going to throw my phone in the
other room so that like yeah
yeah and that's interesting Jerry asked
Joel how is posting a sketch any
different than when you first started
standup which I I guess it's kind of the
same mindset of I we get asked all the
time from people like how do I get on
stage the first time and overcome that
hurdle it is I guess that is kind of
parallel to like overcoming the hurdle
of like actually hitting the upload
button um I guess it's just saying
what's the worst that could happen
totally I think it's exactly the same
thing um in fact I think that uh getting
on stage and doing standup is
harder
yeah I mean yeah for
sure because like you can put something
on the Internet and not get a response
and that sucks but getting up on stage
and being live in person and not getting
lack laughs
is more more painful I would
argue uh on on one of your Tik Tok you
talked about like sort of just having
list of goals and how you're super proud
of after like 15 years of doing this 15
years plus of doing this you put out
your special do you have anything else
that you're sort of like okay sharing
that you like want to get to now that
you've sort of hit that Big Goal um
what's like the big thing that you're
like shooting I want to I sell a show
like a TV show oh yeah yeah so I I've
been I've been working on on something
um and that's the goal for
2024 I love it is it is it based on one
of your characters like based on your
life I think it will be um a wealthy
woman thing we'll see that's so cool
we'll see TBD TBD yeah
exciting and I am hitting upload it's a
it's a video because the lady on let me
let me let me be the first one to
comment
trash that way you just get it out of
the way I'll be the first toone just get
it out of the way that's so generous of
you because Carolyn Xavier starts all
hers with like hey I'm the recovering
californi here like she always opens up
with that like hook yeah so um for these
I did a few of like hey it's trophy
husband
Joel recover in California she's like
that's funny immediately so people may
want to stay um so basically yeah I just
I just uploaded it yes good for you I'm
gonna be famous hey guys be famous
well I love I posted one yesterday and
then after it didn't blow up I was like
I need to edit it down more I I need to
tighten it up and then I just tighten it
up and posted it again and it's like
probably even less views than the first
yeah I do that too where I'm like oh I
it must be because I didn't cut it off
at this exact point let me just let me
just get in there and fix it it's like
no it wasn't that it's just well because
when you research like especially short
form content like and like people are
like oh every breath and syllable counts
and like you know like they really will
get it down to like a molecular level
but I guess you know you don't have to I
guess or are you that meticulous with
your
editing um I mean I obsess over over the
over the writing I think um to a certain
extent you know I think it's this
constant like Battle of like
perfectionism versus just getting it out
there and moving along you know because
it's like the way we consume is so fast
these days and it's just like scroll
scroll scroll so
like you know I I I I get it to a place
where I am
like good this is good enough and then
uh but you can't I don't think I you can
obsess over a short form video for days
you
know how much time would you say you
spend on one like but from the scripting
to the
recording to the editing like how much
time you think goes into like a 60c
video uh it it depends um I feel like
once I have the seed and that's what
takes I feel like that's what takes the
time is like finding the the in finding
the thing that I'm like okay this is
what this is going to be um you know if
I have that then I would say the writing
of like like wealthy woman for example
like probably take
takes an hour two
hours uh sometimes I'll like write a
draft step away come
back
um and then the
recording
takes also probably about an
hour uh the there's no editing because I
just do that in one take if I do one
that's
edited that takes 30 30 minutes to an
hour um depending on what it is is
standup Clips take a little longer um
yeah
so I also started with the wealthy woman
I started using a teleprompter because I
uh there's like it just is like a lot to
get out in a
minute Mar yeah yeah it feels like a
cheat but I don't know we've been doing
it for ages yeah yeah yeah and something
to learn yours are also visuals so it's
like when someone's flicking through
just seeing your video is almost like a
hook in itself of like oh what is that
yeah yeah that's smart too yeah thanks
it's just something to notice of how
people can yeah differentiate their
content as we're all like almost like
playing the lottery every time like
learning from those little details of
how you're able to find Success With It
really can hopefully I
mean this baby
the one well thank you so much for your
time I um I definitely went ahead and
upgraded my zoom account just so we
could get all this in so I definitely
appreciate um you've taken the extra
time here yeah of course this was really
really great it's really fun to to like
dig into the nitty-gritty and I I it's
I'm really it it's really fun to talk
about so thank you for uh letting me
talk for asking such like such good
specific questions yeah I I have one
more question for you before we go uh
like what is the one thing that you'd
give like you know because this
community is you know we started a
couple years ago and it's really like up
andc coming comedians who have started
their comedy career what's the one piece
of advice you give to Comics now who are
sort of in this thick of social media
comedy and trying to like get their
stuff out is there like one piece of
advice that you've heard or that you use
or that you would give to comedians
today I mean it's it's pretty like it's
pretty basic obvious advice but it's
just like
just I'm just going to say the Nike
slogan uh just do it like just just put
it just put it out just like move you
know I think that the the enemy is
um what's it called not movement what's
that stasis
stasis yeah
I think that's the enemy like like
just it's gonna be I think it's like
it's gonna it's probably maybe gonna be
bad it's gonna be bad for a minute and
you have to just like be okay with that
like and for me that was like Tik Tok
was like it was okay for me to be bad at
Tik Tok because it wasn't in like it was
just for it felt like it was for nobody
so I think just being comfortable with
like not being amazing right away but
not it's hard to
do oh you cut out there for a second
just being bad and then what you said uh
just just getting a little bit
comfortable with like not being perfect
and and not letting that paralyze you um
which is really hard you know but like
the most important thing is is movement
I think and
output and then build momentum on that
yeah yeah because you'll get better like
you'll get better so like and you'll get
better faster than you think in my
opinion I'm I'm about to blow up y'all
like I'm I don't even like she said
you're gonna be get better faster than
you think we that was the one right
there and it'll surprise you and I think
also
like do it because you like to do it and
do your best to like throw the
expectations out the window you know I
think that
like if you can just be like this is fun
and this makes me
happy and and if it if it blows up
that's a perk also a lot easier said
than
done you're still a realist yeah I
freeze
again for a second but we caught you
saying but it's easier said than done
yeah
whatever I
said so where um we'll definitely put
links to your social media and um of
course your new special available on
Amazon right now
spiraling um yeah where um do you want
to say what all would you like to
promote let it let it rip um I think
yeah just the just the special which is
it's on Amazon it's on Apple TV it's on
Google Play It's on it's also on YouTube
it's on a bunch of places um oh and no
that's fine I mean it's it's on there it
is on there um
uh in the Dismount I blew it ruined
it that video
down it down um that's yeah that's the
main thing and then just just my social
media um I'm I'm on tour I'm constantly
updating my tour date so that's all on
my on my website or on my social media
um yeah
beautiful well Leah thank you so much
for being on here thank you to everyone
that joined us in the zoom thank you
those of you that are listening to this
afterwards go support Leah she took time
to do this so go watch her special reach
out to her on social media and let her
know you enjoyed this and if you want to
get more info about more q&as we're
doing just join our email list that is
linked in the description of this
episode as well and yeah if you're ever
in the Atlanta area holler at yoshian
Joel we'd love to hang out uh and nerd
over comedy this is heck yeah yeah
absolutely heck yeah I will well y'all
have a good day out there thank you so
much for your time again y'all we love
you all have a good day bye